okay thanks video whoa what just
happened so I did a video a little while
ago talking about my research journey
from school to PhD and a topic which I
briefly touched on in that video which
apparently a lot of people want to know
more about is how I arrived at my area
of research so for those of you who
might be new to the channel my area of
research was in atmospheric physics I
wrote my thesis on a stratospheric
dynamics and that's kind of interesting
because I went to university wanting to
do something in fusion research to
explain how I ended up doing atmospheric
physics instead I should give you two
pieces of background firstly why I was
interested in fusion and secondly what
being taught physics a uni is like when
I was a kid I was super interested in
science but specifically biology I
wasn't actually that interested in
physics I couldn't really told you what
physics was when I was a kid but I knew
from childhood obsessed with dinosaurs
and reading books by Gerald Durrell I
was super into the environment and from
a young age I was aware of the issue of
global warming and climate change and
that it was in a way the defining issue
of our times and so I was determined to
do something specifically in relation to
that with my life later when I went to
school and science as a subject was
split into physics biology and chemistry
I realized that all the cool stuff was
in physics and so I knew I wanted to
study physics so I had to think of a way
to combine those two things of taking
physics or the stuff that I was learning
in class and applying it in some way to
make the environment better and then as
now the kind of big hope for the futures
nuclear fusion clean unlimited source of
energy and so I decided that that was
what I wanted to dedicate myself to
however when I got to university I
realized that actually the physics of
nuclear fusion is pretty much settled
it's not a physics problem anymore it's
an engineering problem of how we
practically do it and when it came to
that I realized that my enthusiasm kind
of waned that really wasn't what I
wanted to do I knew I wasn't at heart an
engineer and so I went
through my physics degree not really
having a specific motivating force
behind what I wanted to do I wasn't sure
if I wants to go into industry or into
research or into teaching or anything
really
I was basically keeping my options open
and the way that you're taught physics
at least in the UK and I guess this is
specifically at Oxford is that you do
idealize cases of things you know when
you're doing Newtonian mechanics you're
dealing with smooth spheres on
frictionless surfaces it never really
felt terribly real so perhaps that
explains why when I got to my third year
and I done mechanics and thermodynamics
and Quantum's there in lecture dynamics
and optics and circuits and all these
things which weren't really as you
experience them in the real world when I
came across the third year module which
was fluids flows and complexity I kind
of fell in love really the John Green
quote about falling in love like you
fall asleep slowly then suddenly all at
once was pretty much true for me in the
field basically I took this module and
for the first couple of weeks of the
course you're dealing with problems
about the navier-stokes equations which
is like the master equation of how
fluids move generally and also you know
considering what is a fluid and I was
sort of plodding along and thinking this
is actually cool this this feels like
something that you know you can use in
the real world it's a continuous medium
that you can describe in just a couple
of equations not like a perfect sphere
like on frictionless surface this was
not a point particle but a medium a
continuous medium and I was thinking man
this is this is cool this is you could
describe the atmosphere like this and
then when we did I think there was an
extension problem on one of the problem
sets applying these equations to a it
was a liquid between two plates though
heated and it was actually a question
that they told us not to worry about
because it wasn't on the syllabus for
that particular year they changed it
around and I did it anyway because the
idea of combining heating the fluid with
change and that uncaused that heating
changing how it moves suddenly sold me I
just suddenly had this this connection
with it I was like that is how you
describe a real-world system that is how
you describe the ocean
atmosphere and I think pretty much from
that problem sheet onwards I just knew
that that was what I wanted to do I'd
sort of refound my focus because it
connected back to climate it connected
me back to the real world and sort of
allowed those two things which I was
really interested in in physics and
analytically describing things and the
real world and the biosphere and
combining them together into one subject
which I didn't even know existed at the
start of my degree so that determine the
area of physics that I was interested in
but then more than that I ended up doing
stratospheric dynamics and that is
something of a different story I think I
speak for most physics PhDs at least in
the UK when I say the PhDs are typically
picked by the students it's quite
unusual from the people that I know to
actually go to university with a
research proposal saying this is exactly
what I want to do because by the end of
your degree you only have a cursory
experience of the different bits of
physics and even in the area that you're
really interested in having done it at
masters level you don't have a huge
depth of experiments to draw on so
typically students will actually pick
from PhD proposals that supervisors put
forward and they say these are the
projects were offering this year and so
when I applied to Oxford and reading I
had a look at the projects that were
available and I decided on ones which
sounded interesting like a shortlist
then it met with the supervisors and
determine which ones I ultimately wanted
to apply for the project I apply for
Oxford which I was offered the place
that was on stratospheric dynamics with
Professor Leslie gray and it was more
solar based it was coupling of the solar
forcing in stratospheric dynamics and I
basically picked that because it had
ramifications for climate change it had
very real you know if I did research
well it could have very real impacts but
I also chose it because Leslie as a
supervisor had a fantastic track record
all of her students said she was lovely
and that she knew what she was doing and
so I just thought on the whole this
start like a good project for me it
matched some you know it there was
enough overlap with what I was
interested in combined with the other
things from make me interested in it
it's then at this point where I didn't
have an active hand in what happened
next
because for those of you who know this
before I basically lost that in my place
at Oxford because of funding
disappearing and I was offered a place
instead of Exeter which was set up by
Professor gray with my actual eventual
supervisor professor mark Baldwin that
was also in Stratos Farah dynamics
because that was what the original
project that I was gonna be working on
was in and so I suppose I did have
ultimate kind of control over what area
I did my research in but that was a
definite jump that was a definite link
that I had minimal control over which is
gonna be kind of a fringe case that
that's not normal for PhDs but that was
what happened with me that then narrowed
things down from physics 12 is ferric
physics to stratospheric dynamics but
then even within that there was the
tiniest sub branch of quasi GS terrific
coupling of the stratosphere and
troposphere in the aftermath of southern
stratospheric warming which is what I
ended up doing my research on and how I
arrived at that was probably about 50%
informed by what my supervisors
expertise was in he kind of discovered
the phenomena that ended up researching
but about 50% based on kind of going
back to why I did a physics degree in
the first place which was playing around
with equations and playing around with
pencil and paper and describing physical
systems analytically this was an area of
research that I could derive a new
theory and so set it out in equations
and test it it wasn't purely statistics
based it wasn't going out in the field
and collecting measurements it was an
abstracted representation of a real
physical system as closely as possible
via just a couple of equations
describing a continuous medium so it was
going back to the roots of why I got
interested in physics in the first place
which is kind of nice really you know
you have the initial driver for why I
got into the field narrowed down by sort
of various circumstances and problems
that I did and then that last bit of
specialization was determined by the
very first thing that got me into the
field in the first place basically I
just followed my gut this is the advice
that I would give to people when they
asked me about you know choosing your
specialism within physics is to follow
your guts just to trust your gut
instinct of course you have to be
exposed to different areas of physics to
be able to do that so don't feel like
you have to choose an area early on I
didn't decide on what I wanted to do my
PhD
really until at the end of third year
there was between 30 and 40 I did a
research project over the summer and I
decided I definitely want to do a PhD
and I want to do it in this area so that
was super late on in my degree and I was
only able to make that decision because
I have been exposed to pretty much every
branch of physics the Oxford physics
course is very broad so I had that
knowledge to be able to make that call
so I say to people if you're watching
this and you're worried about picking a
subfield take your time be exposed to
different bits of physics and see what
grabs your attention and hopefully you
will just find a few it like I did and
just fall in love with it and when you
know you know so get exposed to a lot of
subfields before making your decision
and ultimately trust your gut you know
better than anybody else what you're
interested in and your interest in what
you're gonna do in your research is the
single most important thing that will
get you through your research and allow
you to survive that was how I made my
decision and that's my personal advice
to anyone who's watching this but if you
are watching this and you are a
researcher or you know you're currently
doing your PhD how did you end up at
your subfield because I imagine
everybody has a slightly different story
I hope with commonalities basically
meaning following your gut but I'd like
to hear your story as well leave that
down in the comments this was a very
rambley video it's the first one in a
long time and I haven't actually
scripted so I hope I was able to salvage
something of this in the Edit I hope
that you enjoyed it if you did do
popular like leave your research story
down there in the comments and thank you
again for watching I'll see you next
time